Film Courage: You said something in another interview
about seeing the movie The Crying Game [1992 - Written/Directed by Neil Jordan]
and that you learned from either seeing it
or not being able to see parts of it you
learned about boundaries and censorship
from the point of like an audience or
something. I was just wondering if you
can expand on that because I thought
that was fascinating
and cool story? Orson Oblowitz, Filmmaker/Photographer: and everything yeah well
so Sherman I have a predilection to make
violent movies I've always been
attracted to them kind of harsh
realities and violent instances and
that's where creatively I am attracted
to so it all started and I got one point
pinpoint at this moment my mom my mom
was a single mom bring me up in New York
and she wanted to go see the film The
Crying Game
over at the Angelika film the Angelika
Film Center in New York City so she took
me cuz she couldn't get a babysitter so
I went with her and there's a very
violent scene in The Crying Game
with a that's a great Irish actor's name
I can't remember his name Steven Rae
there's a violent scene with Steven Rae
and a and the love interest who's also a
transvestite and my mom knew it was
coming
so she said hey she took me she took me
outside the theater and said can you you
know sit with an usher and I'm gonna go
watch the Z because I wanted to see the
film but you knew was coming cuz her
friends had told her so you know so I
knew well I'm not supposed to watch this
like I got to see this so in the doorway
of the Angelika Film Center was a
portable that you could see into the
theater and I watched the scene through
the porthole out of the door with no
sound and it was at a moment that I knew
I wanted to make I wanted to be part of
transgressive cinema where I and I
couldn't put a word on it then but now I
think I understand more is it that I
wanted to to break down that that
doorway between the audience the between
what you're not supposed to see and what
you can see and I think that's what I
learned in that moment
this idea that as an audience member you
know there's these violent moments and
were allowed these glimpses into them
and there was like a certain voyeurism
sort of a certain taboo that I wasn't
being allowed in on and that's all I
ever wanted to do since then in these
films so yeah that movement was very so
uh informative to my to to later you
know twenty years later when I started I
actually got the chance to make a movie
and I realized why do I have this
predilection for violence why do I want
to always push it it's because it was
something that was taken away from me
that I couldn't have and that even draw
it drew me closer to it that's
interesting because it goes back to what
you said earlier about like living these
two different realities and and how
there's people that could be right next
to you and they're living in different
reality than you and I can remember
being younger and I grew up in somewhat
of a conservative town and there were
kids that I played with it weren't
allowed to watch Public Television and
to me I wasn't you know I was watching
Three's Company and that was probably
too progressive for my age you know and
so just think that's interesting that
that having been sort of kept from you
oh yeah I mean that's what's fascinating
to me right and I think that's like kind
of what's created great I mean look at
Scorsese or Paul Schrader right both
grew up in very conservative religious
households right Paul Schrader didn't
CFL until he was over 18 and all his
films kind of deal with violent is lack
of faith this alien aided outsider in a
world that doesn't want him so it's
totally affected them I on the other
hand was almost allowed to see too much
so this moment of not being allowed to
see something was really and being
inhibited really to me prove that there
were boundaries that people didn't want
you to crosses the viewer but I wanted
to cross them so I think yeah it's the
same thing right like we we're products
of our environment I think that might
push us totally in the other direction
that intended by you know the person in
charge very true yeah and you were
raised by two artists which is
interesting because most people it seems
like a lot of people are raised by
people that aren't artists and then they
prevent their kid
from winning the arts because they want
to save them from some of the the harsh
realities of doing anything creative
so how was that being raised by by
either one person or knowing that two
parents that you had were creative I
mean it was a pretty interesting
childhood for sure you know my mom and
dad they came here from South Africa in
the 70s to escape apartheid and not they
were just very anti apartheid and anti
the political systems of Africa at the
time so they came here and my dad was a
filmmaker my mom was an actress and you
know eventually they went their
different ways and my dad moved out to
LA became a filmmaker and he always told
me he was like you don't want to do this
he was like oh be a doctor be a lawyer
whatever you do do not become a
filmmaker so of course I was like womp
becoming a filmmaker that dad said no
probably shouldn't listen to him and you
basically have to be a lawyer half the
time in this industry anyway but um and
then my mom on the other hand was
extremely supportive and I lived with
her most my life in New York and she was
always you know like be creative helping
me create supporting creativity bought
me a still camera when I was very young
that I used all the time to take photos
with and that was kind of my first inlet
into film so it was interesting and then
I also watched my dad who you know he
had a lot of struggle he made some great
films and had some struggles with films
and he's and it was you know the
industry wasn't always the best to him
and and it changed and you know he's
always managed to keep up with it and do
his thing but so I have very much a
first-hand glimpse into also you know
this is a really hard industry this is
and that it goes back to lala land right
I think lala land starts with the thesis
that it's a hard industry but that makes
it seem like it's very easy and for me I
think there's a lot of us that you know
we put a lot we let a lot ride on the
filmmaking be a filmmaker being an
artist and what it doesn't work out it
really hurts and I saw that firsthand as
well and I've had it happen to me
firsthand but different you know with
you put something out there and maybe
there's sponsors and what you wanted and
it's like your child so yeah as I was
very lucky to have supportive parents
and I was lucky to have an insight and
I'm
crazy that I wanted to go do this but I
couldn't imagine doing anything else in
the world I get the sense that maybe I
told you this one we had joined the
panel but that you've always been like
two decades ahead of people like even
growing up what was that hard for you
I'm not just assuming I shouldn't assume
but I could see that in you that you
were like more advanced than maybe some
other kids I don't know if I was I mean
I went through a lot of honestly I have
a lot of personal trials and
tribulations I went through growing up
so I think creatively I got I I was I
was allowed to express myself at an
early age and there was no pushback
against that and that was very important
on the other hand I think with that I
was a terrible student
I was not great Oh a socially younger
you know got in a lot of trouble kind of
rested all that stuff like so that came
with that so I think you know there is a
give and take to everything but I am
very grateful that I got to be creative
at a young age and that was supported
and that no one ever really pushed me in
any other direction and I feel blessed
in that's the way because I know a lot
of people who are amazing filmmakers now
and it took a lot you know they had to
reject their family's wishes and move
away from home and go far away and
they're super successful in really
fantastic artists but there came from
the opposite where they really had to
push back against the world that they
were brought up so you know I think it's
you know the luck of the draw a little
bit I think on your website you had a
quote that just said that um you have to
be obsessed or maybe it was a QA you
have to be obsessed to make this work so
I just think that's interesting I mean
because if you know that you had
struggles before sometimes people take
an easier path but if I think if you've
dealt with risk and just always feeling
like stuff's not gonna work out then
you're willing to take sort of the
longshot I don't know yeah I mean I
think you have to be obsessed like
there's there's no get-rich-quick scheme
in the film at least in my version of
his film industry like you want to make
personal films or you're not getting
rich the next day when it comes out you
probably have to put your own money your
own credit your own time
family your own relationships on the
line and that's only worth it if you are
absolutely obsessed and no one can tell
you to be obsessed you're just gonna be
obsessed it's not it's gonna overwhelm
you and take you and then in the end of
the day you're gonna have to give put it
out in the world and when it comes out
there you're done you know you've done
your job and yeah I really do think that
this is a film industry uh that
filmmaking more than the industry
because industries all other thing but I
think almost anyone who works in the
film industry is absolutely crazy you
have to be right yeah you just
there's no reason is you can work in a
bank you can have a great life but for
me it's kind of like I get one shot at
this life and like this is what I love
and I even like many days you know only
have a hundred dollars my fake account
but it doesn't matter because I get to
make a movie I get to work I get to
write I get to have great conversations
with people it opens outlets in your
life that no money or career
opportunities could open for you I know
I've known a lot of people that work
corporate jobs that aren't happy and
then it manifests into office politics
and you know because you're dealing with
the same set of people saying dynamic
almost everyday and I think that people
start to get crazy there too I think
it's just a contained crazy absolutely
but you know I think also like you know
we're all trying our best to survive in
this crazy world and there's you know
all the rules that people give us seem
to change all the time
so you know I think there's no I think
there was a time of my life where I used
to think you know you can do a corporate
job that you know whatever that's you
but I it's all it's all just your path
and like your journey and as a filmmaker
like you're gonna you're gonna be
miserable a lot of the time you're gonna
be sad you're gonna think you're
terrible at what you do I mean I was
going through it recently like I'm
adding a new film and some days like I
just want to press the delete button on
the whole thing you know like I just
don't want it I don't even want to look
at a frame of it anymore but you got it
because it's yours and it honors the
only reason you have to is because if
you don't no one else will do you think
that comes from being so close to it
every day because now you can get sick
of
even if it's excellent but it's just
like you're facing it every day and it
goes back to the same thing with the
workplace you're in the same place every
day so then stuff manifests oh
absolutely I think it's all about you
know I'm actually it's so funny you say
because I'm very much going through this
process that I'm struggling with right
now I have a new film that I've been
making and I I wrote directed I shot it
and I'm editing it and a lot of that was
out of just a financial necessity
because when you're doing small low
budget films there's just certain of
voids you you may have to film along the
way be is that's just the way I imagine
making the movie I think that was it was
kind of this mercurial process I saw and
I said I want to try this and again it
comes back to obsession
I'm obsessed and control Frank and I
think almost all filmmakers are control
freaks actually everyone I met and I'm
very messy in my life but my films where
I get to like be the control freak
uh-huh and and going back to that I
think you get so close yeah I was so
funny I was talking to a friend today he
said how are you doing on the edit and I
go dude I'm so deep in the woods I don't
even know which end I'm coming out on
and he was like he was like yeah but you
know this one day will this will end and
you're gonna come out on one side of the
woods so just keep going and that's kind
of you know the you know it's like the
Elizabeth Warren uh what's her or the
Elizabeth Warren slogan you know she
persisted you know that's kind of the
way filming something to persist you
have to persist at every step of it but
yeah it is very hard to be close and
it's very hard to detach yourself from
something that you really love you know
and let it go in every edit is you
letting go of something you love and
then it turns to you hating it and then
you're kind of in a crazy place well
with the queen of Hollywood how was that
once you screamed it and then I think
you have distribution for it right yeah
so and then like the whole sort of
sexiness of filming it is over the
editing part where maybe it's more
traumatic and then now it's out in the
world what is that like
the good and the bad of that Wow
making Queen was one of the most if not
the most transformative experience I had
as a human being there was a lot that
went of reasons why I made that film I
was going through some very personal
dark situations around me and I
basically was like I understand this
world I have to make a film at this
point because I don't really know where
else to go and then I made it I shot it
you know getting it the whole process
every process is hard right like you
have no money you're begging people for
money and the amazing thing is people
help you and that's one of things like
the first step I learned along the way I
guess the method is that people were
there and really excited to be part of
it from the get-go and a small team
formed and the bigger team formed and
then we were shooting and it was the
most amazing experience ever
and then I edited that film for almost a
year I was so obsessed and so not sure
what it was and I had another editor
Kelly McGillicuddy on it for a couple
months and my producers Matt and Jeff
they were also editors so they'd come in
and edit like it was kind of this crazy
process and we'd sent it to festivals
and we get rejected and then a festival
would say no we want you actually we're
not gonna take you it just a crazy I
mean I many stories no one's you know
you never know and then I had a party I
met Michael rap she runs Dark Star
pictures and we just hit it off and I
sent him the film I mean I went through
every other channel in the world here
supposed to go through and I met a guy
at a party who was like I dig this film
let's do it and you know he worked
really closely with me we distributed it
it came out in theaters played a bunch
of cool festivals it you know and I
don't think you're ever satisfied you
always think you know you're so obsessed
that you're like this is the greatest
thing in the world and it's great to you
but you know there's a lot of films out
there there's a lot of art out there and
you just have to let it be and you have
to let it live you have to let it find
its own life and that was a big
experience I learned but I loved it I
mean there's nothing
you know there's there's honestly
nothing more satisfying than being able
to go on like Amazon and just type your
film in and it comes up and you know
what it doesn't matter if one person
sees it or 1 million people see it like
that's your baby and it's out in the
world and it's all worth it just just to
let it to know that it lives and that it
will live but it's a lot of work you
know and it's it's not always that's the
thing that goes back to the Long Island
statement right you know it kind of
keeps going back to that which is like
that film tells us that like if you do
work and you find success it will all be
great not as great as you thought
because you could have had this other
you gave up love but it's still pretty
great and it's hard the whole process is
hard and it's difficult and it's
alienating but we again we do it because
we're obsessed crazy people and we feel
we have a story to tell and those
stories are important that anyone who
has and tells me
you